foreign
[Music]
about 10 of people will experience an
eating disorder during their lifetime
and yet Eating Disorders are profoundly
misunderstood misconceptions about
everything from symptoms to treatment
make it difficult to navigate an eating
disorder or support someone you love as
they do so so let's walk through what is
and isn't true about eating disorders
first what is an eating disorder Eating
Disorders are a range of psychiatric
conditions characterized by these main
patterns of behavior restricting food
intake binging or rapidly consuming
large amounts of food and purging or
eliminating calories through vomiting
laxatives excessive exercise and other
harmful means
an eating disorder can involve any one
or any combination of these behaviors
for example people living with anorexia
usually restrict the amount of food they
eat while bulimia nervosa is an eating
disorder characterized by recurrent
binges and purges
importantly these behaviors determine
whether someone has an eating disorder
you can't tell whether someone has an
eating disorder from their weight alone
people who weigh what medical
professionals might consider a healthy
range can have Eating Disorders
including severe ones that damage their
long-term Health in invisible ways
including osteoporosis anemia heart
damage and kidney damage
just as we can't tell whether someone
has an eating disorder based on their
weight alone we can't get rid of these
disorders simply by eating differently
that's because Eating Disorders are at
their core psychiatric illnesses from
what we understand they involve A
disruption to someone's self-perception
most people who experience them are
severely critical of themselves and
Report many self-perceived flaws
they may use eating to try to regain
some control over an internal sense of
Chaos
we still don't know exactly what causes
Eating Disorders there likely isn't a
single cause but a combination of
genetic and environmental risk factors
that contribute
sometimes other mental illnesses like
depression or anxiety can cause symptoms
of eating disorders
in addition certain psychological
factors such as perfectionism and Body
Image dissatisfaction are risk factors
for eating disorders
several social factors contribute to
including internalized weight stigma
exposure to bullying racial and ethnic
assimilation and limited social networks
although there is a common misconception
that only women experience Eating
Disorders people of all genders can be
affected
as these disorders intimately affect the
development of one's identity and
self-esteem people are particularly
vulnerable to developing them during
adolescence
although these are among the most
challenging psychiatric disorders to
treat effective therapies and
interventions exist and many people who
receive treatment make a full recovery
treatment has a higher chance of success
the earlier it starts after someone
develops disordered eating behaviors but
unfortunately less than half of people
with an eating disorder will seek and
receive treatment
because of the complex effects of eating
disorders on both the body and the mind
treatment usually includes a combination
of nutritional counseling and monitoring
psychotherapies and in some cases
medications
evidence-based psychotherapies exist as
treatments for most Eating Disorders
including cognitive behavioral therapy
and family-based therapy
these are talk therapies that help
people gain the skills to deal with
underlying psychological problems that
drive eating disorder symptoms
because not all patients will respond to
these treatments researchers are also
investigating treatments outside of
psychotherapy such as transcranial
magnetic stimulation
proper treatment can reduce the chances
of dying from a severe eating disorder
Eating Disorders can provoke a powerful
sense of powerlessness
but education for individuals families
and communities helps erode the stigma
and improve access to treatment
foreign